do you remember how I said just over
here right that you get these numbers
coming up in right angled triangles over
and over again okay and that's because
these are the nice whole numbers where
you get like a happy triangle that sits
if I made it like you know four seven
what's the third side it's gonna be some
doubled up mess with like the last four
numbers in that kind of it so that's why
they tend to be avoided okay now the
same kind of thing happens with trig
ratios but instead of sides it's angled
okay there are some special angles I
don't listen up for you where these
ratios they have special values so lips
no subheading under here which is
special values
okay as a few of these but just this
morning for the sake of time I'm just
going to go through three okay they are
30 degrees 45 degrees and 60 degrees
okay here's where we're going to begin
we'll start with the smallest 130
degrees okay I want you to reach for
your calculator HP tech there and I want
you to punch in I mean out of the three
trig ratios we usually start with sign
they would so for 30 degrees I want you
to punch in what's sine 30 same thing
yeah
ah-ha you should get 0.5 on your
calculator which is a little bit
surprising because if you just go like
you've done inside 30 just assign 31
just for the sake of it okay when you
put that in okay you don't get something
nice to meet you get these decimal
points you're feeding on and on forever
okay you get a get a disaster basically
so sine 30 is special okay
it's a huh now taking advantage of
exactly what we just did see this over
here we said they didn't give you a
diagram but it kind of implies a diagram
doesn't it right it implies this
triangle well this is the diagram here
but it kind of implies one right it
implies a triangle like this
okay 30 degrees looks like it's a small
angle so I'm gonna chuck it in a video
photo 30 degrees over there and it's
sign it's sorry which pair of sides is
that telling me about again it's
opposite hypotenuse opposite over
hypotenuse that should be 1 over 2 now
again just like I did here if I know two
sides in a right-angled triangle I can
pre pretty quickly work out this third
side right that's actually doing this
one we do it with Reid Pythagoras
if I call this side of a key X I'm not
gonna write it in for a second because
we will work it out what can I write
with what can i right that's true
out of Pythagoras about X look I can say
x squared right plus one squared the
other side should be 2 squared good a
squared B squared C squared that's fine
I know what one spit is I know what 2
squared is x squared plus 1 equals 4
right so x squared should be 3 so what's
X it's just a square root 3 right now
it's worth mentioning x squared equals 3
there are actually two solutions to that
not just one the one that we wrote down
is the positive square root of 3
there's also the negative square root of
3 because if you square that guy you'll
still be 3 right but I didn't need to
worry about that solution at least in
this case why not what I needed to worry
about the negative square root of 3
yeah I have a leg here I'm working out a
distance okay so that thing has to be
positive right so that's my answer so
that's what I'm going to put down here
okay so there's the square root of 3 now
that I know all three sides in here I
don't just know sine 30 I can also work
out cos 30 and tan 30 and they should
give me these nice numbers right I
should be able to say cos 30 is going to
be adjacent over hypotenuse right root
3/2 yep and lastly 10 for this angle tan
30 that's gonna be opposite on adjacent
103 okay
now you might think okay I've done 30
I've done all three ratios for 30 seems
like a logical next step to go to 45
you could go to 45 but it's not a
logical next step
can anyone see why the logical next step
is 60 number one number one it's double
the size you like okay that's that's
kind of a nice link between them but
more importantly think about what I've
been looking at the last twin is they're
complementary
you see that they're complementary so
these guys are complements okay
so therefore sine 60 and cos 60 and ten
I should be able to work out just by
looking at these ones I already to know
right so for instance let's think about
sine 60 sine 60 should be equal to cos
30 remember that's the relationship
between these two guys yeah and I've
written down cos 30 already there is
three three on suit cos 60 that should
be sine Bay because these guys have
continents and that was the very first
one over it down that's a hot now ten
sixty a little bit tricky approach that
right 1060 remember we started off we
said well ten is really sign on cause
you agree with that that's that's
literally its definition okay but I just
worked out what each of these arms right
they're going to be cos sine right so
this company is just like this guy but
upside down see this is sine 30 on
closed ad but this one is upside down
cos 30 on sine 30 they're reciprocals
with each other
you see this so what's the reciprocal of
103 it's just read three like the
reciprocal of one on root 3 is just 4 3
so then you go you can see these are
special values because rather than you
go to calculate up and you get some
rubbish out of that you like what does
that even equal to you know exactly what
these are equal to which is why another
name for these are the exact value to
the trigonometric versions right we do
30 we did 60 last one
okay we drew this one diagram right and
it covered thirty and sixty that's nice
it's cuz they're compliments yeah it's
not gonna cover forty-five I need a new
diagram
what's that diagram gonna look like
we're starting by writing the trend
okay now if I make one of the angles 45
like that one of them left you do the
angle of some of the triangle
what's the other one it's also gonna be
45 isn't it right coz 45 this is a funny
thing
thirty and sixty of complements but 45
is its own complement right
he's like the ultimate antisocial guys
like I don't need any of you guys I'll
do a compliment with myself
okay so 45 and 45 they exist in both
quarters okay now if I've got two equal
angles over here over here right what
does that tell me about these two sides
over here right this triangle is
isosceles right degree with that so if
this guy and this guy are equal I'm just
going to say like I just made up this
triangle I just made it that'd be okay
I'm gonna make this one and one okay
because they're equal I could have made
it two and two or three and three if I
like we're still gonna get the same
answer out in a second just Pythagoras
again just like we did here okay this
time I'm working out the hypotenuse so I
should be able to say a squared plus B
squared equals C squared 1 plus 1 that's
2 equals this so if C squared equals 2
what's C by itself I had C squared
equals 3 before so I got root 3 so this
is gonna be rich it okay and you can go
ahead if you like you can draw yourself
a triangle that's our 1 centimeter by 1
centimeter and you will find that this
third side has to be at one point 4
centimeters
I've got all three sides I'm ready to go
sine 45 opposite hypotenuse right 1 over
2 very good
I didn't even need to look at the
triangle for the next one because
remember we said cause 45 is its own
Cubs it's like 45 is its own complement
so cos 45 is the same as sine 45 do you
see that because they're complements
right so it's still 100 - okay tan 45
he's the best one of all he's the
simplest of the line opposite opposite
on and Jason absolutely he's just one so
you're gonna tail you've left nine exact
values 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 this is the
first time you've met them so they seem
a bit intimidating because 9 things is a
lot to remember but just like a phone
number memorized a phone number form
that's 10 G 10 D that's right but it's
not that hard if you keep on using it
right so we're gonna work next week on
how to get a little more familiar with
these these triangles are going to be
really important and we're going to use